saudi aramco is a massive business
many of you may not have ever heard of
saudi aramco but saudi aramco
is uh the third largest company in the
world by market cap
they were rumored to start
being interested in mining bitcoin now
as a oil giant
i figured that maybe we should look at
saudi aramco as a business before we
talk about them potentially
mining bitcoin so oh my keys just fell
whatever we're gonna keep going you see
how this that's how you know this thing
is live like
trillionaire energy whatever it's fine
uh the market cap of the company is 1.8
trillion dollars
in 2020 they had revenue of 230 billion
and they booked 49 billion dollars
in profit which was almost
half of what they did in 2019 remember
pandemic oil
not as popular they did 88 billion
dollars in profit
in 2019. they have 66 000
employees how the hell do they make so
much revenue and profit well
they have some of the lowest costs of
production in the world
this comes from the financial times
which source is saudi aramco
so take with that what you want but what
you can see
is that the 2018 full cycle dollars per
barrel
the saudi arabia producing fields was
just over
ten dollars was the cost per barrel
if you compare that to china offshore
they pay almost 70 dollars a barrel to
produce
one barrel of oil if you then look in
the united states
onshore cost is about 45 offshore it
costs us just over 40 bucks
so when the price of oil drops to 20
30 even 40 dollars the united states
companies
are actually under water it costs them
more to produce a barrel of oil
than it does to sell it they lose money
saudi arabia however is the king of the
mountain
they literally can see the price of oil
drop to 11
and they still make money the everyone
else in the industry can be
underwater and saudi arabia will still
be profitable
because their cost of producing one
barrel is so low it is about
one-fourth or about 25 percent of what
it costs u.s onshore or offshore to
produce a barrel of oil
pretty good but if you look at the oil
reserves meaning the
oil that is under the ground saudi
arabia is basically
kings of the world why because the
saudi-owned oil giant has more than
seven times as many oil reserves as the
combined reserves of
exxon and shell that's right exxon and
shell
those are big boy companies everyone in
the western world thinks of exxon and
shell they're like
wow 24.8 billion barrels
and shell 11.7 billion saudi aramco has
seven times more than both of them
combined
and not only do they have seven times
more
barrels than exxon and shell combined
but their cost of production
is at least 25 or less
than what it costs exxon and shell to
produce so if you have seven times
more barrels than both combined and your
cost is 25 percent less
and you simply sell as much as they do
you likely are going to be pretty
profitable
and so if we look at saudi aramco
as the profit king what you can see is
that in 2018
profits from saudi aramco equaled
the combined totals of apple google and
exxon
this is a massive business yeah but
those are small companies
apple google and exxon just some
internet
companies and an energy company that no
one's ever really heard of before
combine up
all their profits and saudi aramco did
the exact same as those three businesses
combined this business
is insane now in the oil production
process
gas is a byproduct and it's often burned
or flared we had already been on the
podcast last week and he talked about
gas flare capture meaning when you flare
the gas
it's really bad for the environment and
if you can capture that
and then convert it into energy and mine
bitcoin you can actually take what is a
waste
something that you do not monetize for
your business even though you're the
profit king
you could then drive more additional
revenue
now it would be a really big deal if
saudi aramco decided to start mining
bitcoin
we know that saudi aramco officials have
been in
telegram channels with bitcoiners for
over a year marty bent steve barber a
number of these folks all reporting
over the weekend that these aramco
officials
have been looking at this stuff they've
been learning about bitcoin and about
bitcoin mining
now when you see that these oil
companies can get more revenue
for a product that they already are
producing and simply burning off
or getting rid of and you also see that
miners can now get
incredibly cheap access to power
you realize that it could create a
win-win solution now
my guess is that as we were going into
today saudi aramco was going to say
exactly what they ended up saying this
morning
which is we deny the report that we were
looking at bitcoin mining
my guess also is that saudi aramco is
absolutely looking at bitcoin mining
and they would have to it is a new
opportunity it is a new potential
revenue stream that could turn
what is a incredibly environmentally
damaging waste stream
from their process into something that
is more environmentally
friendly and could drive significant
revenue
and profit now if you are sitting like
saudi aramco and you have the profits of
combined apple google and exxon you may
not be worried about squeaking out a
couple extra shekels here and there
but if those shekels weren't shekels and
instead they were bitcoin
it may actually drive you to be much
much more interested in it and so
saudi aramco has actually invested in
blockchain platforms they've gone
blockchain not bitcoin
which is yet to be determined data gumbo
and fact v-a-k-t they aid in the
management and automation of new
contracts and
invoices and in 2019 the oil giant
committed to achieving net
zero gas flaring by 2030 and they also
joined a world bank initiative to reduce
flaring
so they've been looking at the space
they've made some investments in
non-mining related
types of opportunities and they've
committed to getting to
zero gas flaring by
2030. the best easiest and most
profitable way to do that
is through bitcoin mining and through
gas flare capture and my guess is that
by 2030 we will see a headline that says
saudi aramco is mining bitcoin it may
not happen today
it may not have started already but when
that happens in the next
eight nine years don't be surprised if
you have cheap power the economic
incentive to mine bitcoin secure
the network and verify transactions of
the strongest computing network in the
world
is too strong you absolutely will have
to join the game
because it is likely that the oil
of which your business is built on will
become less and less valuable over time
as we
move to more clean energy and to more
electric vehicles and other types
of energy sources but the bitcoin will
continue to get more valuable
and so i wouldn't be surprised we have
quotes here from two different people
one
is the head of gasprov neft which is
i think the big russian energy business
says quote energy from associated gas
can power data centers and mining farms
this will increase the percentage of
rational use of raw materials
this is especially true for remote
regions of siberia and the arctic
where the transportation of associated
gas from the fields is unprofitable
so something that is unprofitable can
now be profitable
this isn't saudi aramco but this is
russian gas prof
then we can see the head of mining
operations at wise and trust raymond
nasser who actually had the opportunity
to meet at one point
a very nice guy said quote we are
negotiating with aramco
we are negotiating with aramco all black
liquid oil
that comes out of the desert belongs to
this company all the flared gas they're
not using and that's public information
i can tell you it's not enough to power
up
half or it is enough to power up half of
the bitcoin network today from this
company alone
it's going to happen i don't know when i
don't know who's going to be the company
that gets them to do it
i don't know if it's an interior
internal or external type initiative
reporting in progress my bitcoin at some
point they say not now
i say who knows when but one what do you
think john
win-win situation it perfectly suits
both parties very well
um yeah i i would be very excited to see
this happen i'm not sure why they're
debunking it uh maybe internally for
certain reasons but
well people uh people are are saying hey
they've already debunked this they've
already said it's not true
and and saudi aramco says they're
complete the claims are completely false
and untrue
uh this they obviously wouldn't be the
first company to go back on something
that they said was false or untrue
but my question would really be like why
wouldn't they do this right like this
kind of seems like
a uh a no-brainer from a kind of what
they're already doing
kind of with the gas flares and
everything right now and the economic
incentive that they would have to use
some of that energy to mine bitcoin
like why wouldn't they do it if you're
saudi aramco
this is the most no-brainer thing in the
world you get to run around
the world saying we're not going to hurt
the environment as much as we have been
we're going to become a more profitable
business
and now we're going to hold the bitcoin
on our balance sheet
esg you get to throw that word around
i'm not going to go there but what i
will say is
aramco if you guys want some help call
me
i got i got friends i'm not gonna do
anything but i got friends who will help
you
you